beste Damen und Herren liebe Zuseher von
den sozialen Medien leider ist es so
heuer aufgrund der kogit 19
Einschränkungen und der damit
verbundenen Maßnahmen nicht möglich die
feierliche Angelobung unserer Kameraden
des einrichtungstourens jänner unter
Einbeziehung der Öffentlichkeit
durchzuführen
es freut uns Spitaler
hochgebirgssoldaten umso mehr dass wir
uns mittels Livestream zusehen und somit
live dabei sind wenn unsere jungen
hochgebirgssoldaten und unsere
villacher-
[Musik]
mein Name ist Oberstleutnant Jürgen
Mayer und ich darf Sie durch das
Programm führen
zum feierlichen Festakt der Angelobung
unserer jungen Soldaten sind angetreten
in unserem Sommer der Militärmusik
Kärntens 26
der ehrenzug gestellt durch das
hochgebirgs-jägerkompanie unseres
hochgebirgsjägerbataillons und die
Anzüge loberinnen der
kampfunterstützungs-
der ausgerückten Truppe ist
Oberstleutnant Daniel Wilfing
das erfolgt nun die Meldung der
Feierlichkeit an den Kommandanten der
sechsten gebirgsbrigade dann Oberst Kurt
Flügel im Anschluss erklingt die
Bundeshymne und es erfolgt das
Abschrecken der Front vom Kommandanten
der sechsten gebirgsbrigade Oberst Kurt
Flügel in Beisein von
Bataillonskommandanten der Spitaler
hochgebirgsjäger der Oberst Rudolf Kuri
und dem Bataillonskommandanten der
villacher-land Herbig kleinschnig
[Musik]
26 sowie 140 Anzüge gelungene Rekruten
das jägerbatterien 26 und für eine
Batterie angegriffen
[Musik]
es erfolgt die feierliche Flaggenparade
von zwei Soldaten des hochgebirgs-
[Musik]
es erfolgt nun die Begrüßung und die
Einsprache unseres batalonskommandanten
dann Oberst Rudolf kury
geschätzte Kameradinnen und Kameraden
als Kommandant des
hochgebirgs-26
darf ich euch alle zu unserer heutigen
angelogen hier in der türk-kaserne
herzlich willkommen Hessen
ein ganz besonderer Gruß gilt unseren
Kommandanten der sechsten gebirgsbrigade
Herrn Oberst Kurt Flügel sowie dem
kommando-leitner
Herr Oberst schön dass du heute bei uns
diese angelogen mit uns begehst
herzlich willkommen heißen darf ich
unseren militärgeistlichkeit Herr Dekan
Partner Anselm sowie Herrn militären
Oberpfarrer Johannes Hülser ein
herzliches Grüß Gott
bedanken darf ich mich beim Ensemble der
Militärmusik Kärnten
welches unseren Festakt heute
musikalisch umrahmen wird
da heute mit uns auch die jungen
Kameraden der Villach habt ihr Niere mit
angelobt werden dass ich den neuen
Kommandanten des pionierpataillons eins
ein oberstleuten und kehrweg Glantschnig
bei uns recht herzlich willkommen heißen
der Oberstdorf und ich darf dir Name ist
der Spitaler hochgebirgsjäger vor allem
aber auch persönlich zur Bestellung als
neuer Kommandant des pionierbataillons
eins mit Wirksamkeit von ersten Februar
herzlich gratulieren ich wünsche dir in
deiner neuen Funktion als Bataillons
alles alles Gute viel Glück und eine
gute Hand aber auch viel Freude ich
freue mich auf eine gereilliche
Zusammenarbeit
ja liebe junge Kameraden
aufgrund der derzeitigen kovitsituation
können wir üblicherweise eure angelogen
heute nicht in der Öffentlichkeit
und bei sein politischer Vertreter
Vertreter unserer Gebietskörperschaften
Beisein von uns nahestehenden
Organisationen und Vereinen aber
vor allem aber auch in Beisein eurer
Angehörigen und Freunde durchführen
nichtsdestotrotz wollen wir im üblichen
festlichen Rahmen eure Angelobung
beginnen hier steht heute im Mittelpunkt
und ihr werdet in erster Linie im
Beisein eurer Kommandanten und Kameraden
geloben der Republik Österreich als
Soldat zu dienen
wir übertragen den Festakt mittels
Livestream über Youtube so dass eure
Familie Freunde und Bekannte live dabei
sein können bzw ihr später auch selbst
mit ihnen eure Angelobung ansehen können
ihr seid zu zweit besonderen Bataillonen
eingerückt
und werde ganz speziell als Gebirgsjäger
und Pionier ausgebildet
um gemeinsam mit uns Cara Soldaten auch
ganz spezielle Aufgaben übernehmen und
durchführen zu können
wir haben das große Glück
in einem wunderbaren Land leben zu
dürfen
wir haben eigentlich alles
wir können uns im Prinzip alles leisten
uns geht es sehr sehr gut
und wir können uns glücklich schätzen
und sollten durchaus darauf stolz sein
Österreicher zu sein
wir sollten vielleicht nicht ständig
über alles jammern
alles hinterfragen und zu reden
und vielleicht ab und zu einmal über
unsere Grenzen hinausblicken und die
wirklichen Rahmen und Christen dieser
Menschheit wahrnehmen
so finde ich es durchaus gut und recht
dass jeder seinen Beitrag an diesem
unseren Glück und an unserer
Gesellschaft leistet
mit eurem grundwertdienst leistet dir
einen wesentlichen Beitrag im Rahmen von
Katastropheneinsätzen und
sicherheitspolizeilichen Assistenz
einsetzen gemeinsam mit uns keiner
Soldaten
um unsere Werte und Lebensbedingungen in
Österreich zu erhalten
ich danke euch ganz besonders dafür dass
wir gemeinsam mit uns dafür bereite
ich wünsche euch heute einen schönen
ergreifenden Festakt einen Ehrentag der
euch in Erinnerung bleiben soll
sowie einen aus eurer Sicht sinnvollen
und vor allem aber unfallfreien
Grundwehrdienst sowie viel Soldaten
Glück meine jungen Kameraden alles Gute
mit dem Trompetensignal habt acht und
einem Choral gespielt vom und somit der
Militärmusik Kärnten werden die Worte
der Geistlichkeit eingeleitet
[Musik]
sehr geehrter Herr Brigade Kommandant
sehr geehrte Herren
Bataillonskommandanten Liebe
Kameradinnen und Kameraden vor allem
liebe Rekruten eine kurze Geschichte
der alte Mann aus Afrika hieß Daniel und
er glaubte an Gott
jemand wollte sich aber über ihn lustig
machen und fragte
woher weißt Du Daniel dass es einen Gott
gibt
Daniel antwortete
woher weiß ich ob ein Mensch oder ein
Hund oder ein Esel nach zu meiner Hütte
gegangen ist
an den Spuren im Sand sehe ich es
und so sind auch in meinem Leben Spuren
eingedrückt nämlich die Spuren Gottes
im Rekruten mit der Angelobung setzt ihr
eine bedeutende Wegmarke in eurem Leben
der Grundwehrdienst wird zu einem Teil
eures Lebenslaufes
und er wird Spuren bei euch hinterlassen
und ihr werdet vielleicht auch noch
Jahre später darüber reden er wird euch
prägen in Disziplin und Ordnung in
Pünktlichkeit und Kameradschaft und ihr
werdet Fähigkeiten erlernen die ihr auch
für euer späteres Leben brauchen werdet
aber es gibt natürlich noch viele andere
Faktoren die ein Menschenleben prägen
vor allem die Familie
die jetzt vielleicht zuschauen und
zuhören die Eltern die Geschwister die
Freunde prägen ein Leben aber auch
Lehrer und Schulkameraden oder Kollegen
und Vorgesetzte in der Arbeit
denn hier auf euer Leben schaut könnt
ihr euch fragen gibt es in meinem Leben
bestimmte Spuren die eingeprägt sind
woher kommen sie
welche Spuren sind es die zu mir gehören
und die nicht zu dem machen was ich
heute bin
wir können aber auch Fragen gibt es auch
Spuren in meinem Leben die ich mit Gott
in Verbindung bringen Erfahrungen bei
denen ich für mich denke dass er
irgendwie mit im Spiel gewesen ist
Gott begleitet uns ständig auch wenn wir
es nicht immer wahrnehmen
und wir haben es heute schon gehört oft
erkennen wir nur das Negative in unserem
Leben und jammern darüber der bessere
Blick aufs Leben wäre jedoch das
Positive zu suchen und es lässt sich
leicht finden und darüber auch dankbar
zu sein danken wir Gott dafür dass es
uns in diesem Land so gut geht und auch
ihr tragt durch euren Grund Wehrdienst
dazu bei
was ist das größte Gebot jesus hat
gesagt du sollst Gott lieben und deinen
Nächsten wie dich selbst
haltet Gott die Treue der euer ständiger
Begleiter und Beschützer ist und übt
Nächstenliebe in Versöhnung
Kameradschaft und Hilfsbereitschaft gott
segne euch und euren Dienst im
österreichischen bundesheeren
Liebe Kameradinnen liebe Kameraden aller
Dienst gerade Liebe amtsbiologische
der Militärpfarrer johannes hat gerade
von den Tugenden gesprochen die man
entweder schon als Anlage mitbringt wenn
man zum Militär kommt oder sie hier eben
auch erlernen kann
von Cicero stammt die Erkenntnis
Dankbarkeit
ist nicht nur die größte aller Tugenden
sondern auch die Grundlage für alle
anderen
es hat sowohl der Herr
Bataillonskommandant dass er der
militärfahrer schon angesprochen dass
wir oftmals den Fokus auf die negativen
Dinge legen aber wir dürfen zuallererst
dankbar sein und das hat der Herr
Bataillonskommandant ebenso gesagt in
einem Land wie Österreich zu leben mit
all seinen Möglichkeiten sich auch
entfalten zu können mit seiner sozialen
Sicherheit und wir springende Punkt ist
der hier könnte jeder von uns noch
einige selbst hinzufügen und das sollen
wir auch tun und wenn wir das
tatsächlich auch tun dann werden wir
staunen wie viele Punkte da
zusammenkommen
ein Land
das seinerseits heute
seinen Dank zum Ausdruck bringt für
euren Dienst den ihr leistet
eure Eltern eure Geschwister eure
Freundinnen eure Freunde dürfen mit und
für euch heute dankbar sein
ich wünsche euch für ein Soldatenalltag
dass ihr euch dieses dankbare Herz
bewahrt besonders auch in
herausfordernden Zeiten eures Dienstes
lebt ihn so dass sie selbst Anlass zum
Dank für eure Kameraden werden können
nur noch dem Herrgott heute danken dafür
dass ihr euch mit seinem Segen begleitet
beten wir nun für unser Land für die
Menschen die darin wohnen und für all
jene die es verteidigen
bitte nun den Herrn oberstleitner die
ausgerückte Gruppe zum Gebet des
Vaterunsers Inseln
vater unser im Himmel geheiligt werde
dein Name dein Reich komme dein Wille
geschehe wie im Himmel so auf Erden
unser tägliches Brot wie man es heute
und vergib uns unsere Schuld wie auch
wir vergeben unseren Schuldigern und
führe uns nicht in Versuchung sondern
erlöse uns von dem Bösen denn dein ist
das Reich und die Kraft und die
Herrlichkeit in Ewigkeit haben Herr
unser Gott segne diese jungen Menschen
die heute feierlich geloben die Republik
Österreich im Dienste des Bundesheeres
zu schützen und sich für den Frieden mit
allen Kräften einzusetzen Amen
nach einer Fanfare darf ich nun unseren
Kommandanten unsere 6 gebirgsbrigade
dann Oberst Kurt Flügel um seine Worte
bitten
[Musik]
hohe Geistlichkeit sehr geehrte
des hochgebirgs
1 Gesetze Kameradinnen und Kameraden
Werte Zuseher
diese diese Veranstaltung wir Livestream
verfolgen können aber vor allem sie
Soldaten des einrückungstermins jänner
2022 wir stehen heute hier in der
türkaserne um eine wichtigen Abschnitt
in ihrer Zeit als grundverdiener beim
österreichischen Bundesheer feierlich zu
begehen sie werden am Ende sie werden
heute am Ende ihres ersten
Ausbildungsabschnittes angelockt die
Angelobung haben heutigen Tag findet
unter besonderen Bedingungen statt die
Auswirkungen der Pandemie haben
Maßnahmen notwendig gemacht die es nicht
nur ein privaten sondern auch im
dienstlichen Umfeld erheblich
einschränken
angepasst an diese vorgegebene Maßnahmen
führen wir am heutigen Tag diese
Veranstaltung in einem sehr kleinen
Rahmen durch daher ist es auch nicht
möglich ihren Angehörigen die
Gelegenheit zu bieten sie hier vor Ort
zu begleiten etwas das ich sehr bedauere
da die heutige Angelobung für Sie einen
wesentlichen Abschnitt in ihrer Zeit als
Soldat dasteht die Angelobung bot bisher
die erste Möglichkeit mit den
neueingeregten Grundwehrdienern in der
Öffentlichkeit
aufzutreten ich hoffe dass man via
Livestream etwas von dieser Stimmung
hier in der glück-kaserte miterleben
kann
die Angelobung ist ein symbolisches
Zeichen für ihre Aufnahme in die
soldatengemeinschaft und sie bezeichnet
in Österreich auch die Verpflichtung zur
gesetzestreuen und gewissenhaften
Ausübung übertragener Funktionen mit
einem feierlichen Gelöbnis
sie werden dieses Gelöbnis anschließend
gemeinsam sprechen
darin geloben sie nicht nur treu und
Gehorsam gegenüber Vorgesetzten und
Behörden sie geloben auch um die
Republik Österreich und sein Volk zu
schützen und zu verteidigen bei Bedarf
warten dafür einzusetzen das
österreichische Volk erwartet viel von
ihnen der Dienst als Soldat kann dazu
führen dass sie für die Gemeinschaft
bewusst in eine Gefahr hinein handeln
müssen eine Pflicht die hoffentlich nie
von ihnen eingefordert werden muss
dieses Gelöbnis dass sie noch sprechen
werden weist schließlich darauf hin dass
sie zu dienen haben der Republik
Österreich und dem österreichischen Volk
sie stellen somit sicher dass das
österreichische Bundesheer seinen
Aufgaben nachkommen kann die im gemäß
Verfassung zugeordnet sind
die Kernaufgabe des österreichischen
Bundesheeres ist die militärische
Landesverteidigung es gilt Aggressionen
von außen abzuhalten die Ordnung und
Sicherheit in Österreich aufrecht zu
erhalten und damit das Wertesystem und
ihren mit ihren Wertevorstellungen die
unsere Gesellschaft ausmacht und zu
sichern
die allgemeine Wehrpflicht ist die
gesetzliche Grundlage für diesen Dienst
an der Gesellschaft dass sie hier nun
in Uniform vor mir stehen zeigt dass sie
bereit sind ihren Pflicht ihrer Pflicht
als Staatsbürger nachzukommen und den
Dienst als Soldat zu leisten diese
Entscheidung findet bei mir bei uns
allen hohe Anerkennung
denn sie verzichten damit auch viele
Annehmlichkeiten ihres bisherigen Lebens
und lassen die sogenannte Wohlfühlzone
für diese Zeit hinter sich ihre Zeit
beim österreichischen Bundesheer wird
auch verbunden sein mit
außergewöhnlichen Erfahrungen und
schönen Erlebnissen diese mitnehmen
können und sollen
als Soldat der Gebirgsgruppe und auch
der Pioniertruppe
sind sie Teil einer Elite des
österreichischen Bundesheeres die in
ihrer Ausbildung und bei Einsetzen immer
auch außergewöhnliche
Leistungsbereitschaft zeigt diese hohe
Leistungsbereitschaft verbunden mit
ihrem können nicht nur beim Einsatz im
Gebirge macht die Gebirgstruppe
insbesondere das
hochgebirgsjägerbataillon 26 und
natürlich auch die Pioniertruppe zu
einem verlässlichen und geschätzten
Akteur zu unterstützt Unterstützung der
österreichischen Bevölkerung bei
Bewältigung von Krisen und Ereignissen
besonderen Ausmaßes sie garantieren der
österreichischen Bevölkerung damit in
der Krise Sicherheit Schutz und Hilfe
Erfahrungen aus der umweltbaren
Vergangenheit haben uns gezeigt wie
rasch verschiedene Ereignisse die
Gesellschaft überfordern können und das
österreichische Bundesheer zur
Krisenbewältigung als strategische
Reserve der Republik einspringen musste
und noch muss
für ihren grundverdienst wünsche ich
Ihnen geschätzte Rekruten eine gediegene
und fordernde Ausbildung als
Vorbereitung für die heranstehenden
Aufgaben und natürlich alles Gute und
viel Soldaten Glück
von meinen Kadersoldaten erwarte ich mir
dass sie der ihnen zukommenden Aufgabe
als Vorgesetzte gerecht werden und in
jeder Situation Vorbild sind
behandeln Sie die jungen Erwachsene mit
dem nötigen Respekt aber auch mit der
angemessenen Härte wenn es erforderlich
ist sie sind mir verantwortlich dafür
dass diese junge Menschen für die
heranstehenden Aufgaben ordentlich
ausgebildet werden wenn wir darüber
hinaus noch die den Gebirgsjägern
besonders auszeichnete Eigenschaft der
Kameradschaft pflegen können wir die an
uns gestellten Aufgaben gemeinsam
bewältigen es lebe das
hochgebirgsjägerbataillon 26 das
Pionierbataillon 1 es lebe die sechste
gebirgsbrigade
es folgt nun der eigentliche Höhepunkt
der feierlichen Angelobung
stellvertretend für alle anzügelobenen
werden sechs Rekruten vortreten und den
Treuheit beim Feldzeichen leisten hierzu
tritt der insingen-trupp nun in die
Mitte des Platzes vor
[Musik]
das treue Gelöbnis ist laut und deutlich
nachzusprechen
ich glaube
mein Vaterland
die Republik Österreich
und sein Volk zu schützen
und mit der Waffe zu verteidigen
ich glaube
den Gesetzen
und den gesetzmäßigen Behörden und
Treue und Gehorsam zu leisten
alle Befehle meiner Vorgesetzten
pünktlich und genau zu befolgen
[Musik]
und mit allen meinen Kräften
der Republik Österreich
und dem österreichischen Volker
zu dienen
[Musik]
ehrenzug
Abordnungen eintreten
[Musik]
es erfolgt nun die Beendigung des
Festaktes an den militärisch
höchstanwesenden und das abschließende
abrücken
geschätzte Damen und Herren der
offizielle Teil unserer Feierlichkeit
ist nun beendet ich darf mich nochmals
bei allen Teilnehmern dem umsemble der
Militärmusik Kärnten im insignientrupp
des hochgebirgs-26
dem ehrenzug des
hochgebirgsjägerpartalon 26
sowie den angelobten
villacherpionieren und angelobten
spitalern hochgebirgsjägern auf das
Herzlichste bedanken
ich bedanke mich herzlichst ebenfalls
für zusehen auf den sozialen Medien
bleiben Sie gesund
gut
[Musik]
danke sehr jo jo gratulation für die
ausgezeichnete kommandobierung
angelobte Teile habt acht
angelockte Teile rechts
war der Zug ja Information übernehmen
abrücken ja Informationen übernehmen
es sind nicht gut jeder Batterie 26
ehrenzug jägerpartner 026 auf mein
Kommando ich spreche sie an als
lerninformation irgendwann formation
mehr Informationen
ja Information Schritt
[Musik]